[Music]
Thanks for coming to my talk. I'm
Shazage. Uh I'm one of the co-founders
at Orb. Um and I'm going to be talking
about how to think about pricing. Um
maybe top level takeaway uh from this
talk is that pricing is a is a deep
complicated topic. We're going to cover
some examples. We're going to cover some
tactical advice. Um, but in general, the
way you should think about pricing is
pricing is a form of friction uh for
your product and sometimes that friction
can be applied for very good reason.
Sometimes that friction can just prevent
people from using your product. And so
you really have to think about the value
your product is delivering as well as
the audience you're delivering it to.
Um, and the way that you're building and
innovating in your product to to start
really thinking about pricing. Um, just
a quick uh intro to Orb. Orb is a
usagebased billing infrastructure
company. So we help companies at lots of
layers of the stack um think about
pricing and billing. Uh nowadays a lot
of our conversations first center around
monetization and pricing as a practice
and then we get into the weeds of how do
we actually bill for this stuff.
So uh you know maybe maybe an intro uh
tweet to start. Um this is Amjad. He's
the CEO and founder of Replet. Replet is
one of customers. Um and and this is a
tweet actually pretty recent starting to
think about how Replet agent should
price itself. And so so you know pretty
short tweet but a lot of complexity
actually packed in here. Uh really
starting to think about you know as you
have Replet which is a very popular
agent that you know does programming is
starting to build full stack web apps.
Um how how should a company like Replet
price their agent? Should it be like a
super simple every time the agent
checkpoints it charges you a fixed
amount? um or should it start aligning
with the complexity of the change it
made? Um and as you can start you know
thinking through this question you have
to think through considerations like who
is replet built for right what are the
costs that replet incurs um but also
just the user experience of if I get
charged some amount at the end of
something that this agent has done
without me really having control over
what the agent did other than the
initial prompt um is that going to be
surprising is that not going to be
surprising right so um these
considerations apply particularly to
agents because the work that the agent
is doing is fairly opaque or can be
opaque um but they apply at every layer
of the stack including the kind of
infrastructure layer of the AI stack. Um
so monetization as a whole is changing.
Uh maybe let's start with some kind of
traditional principles in in pricing and
and how pricing has always been thought
about, right? So we're maybe coming from
way back in the day, you know, you're
selling a fixed license. You you go to
like Fries Electronics and and buy your
Turboax license and then of course now
you have seatbased pricing subscription.
maybe you're paying $30 a seat um all
the way to you have this usage based
pricing which is very dynamic and then
maybe you can consider outcomebased
pricing as a further evolution of that.
So in traditional pricing you you have a
few a few key principles. You want to
make sure that the pricing is simple so
that users can actually understand it.
They can gro your pricing. They know how
they're going to pay for your tool. Um
you want to produce some friction
because it it determines the value of
your product. Like willingness to pay is
a very real signal. And then you want to
protect your margins, right? Um,
traditionally software margins have been
very healthy. Uh, you know, a good
software margin looks like 80%.
Obviously, as you start getting closer
to the infrastructure layer and as you
start moving into the world of AI, uh,
these margins are are much much more
variable, not necessarily unhealthy, but
um, there's a lot more degenerate
workloads that that you can incur with
an agent. So, now starting to think
about AI native pricing, predictability
matters a lot, right? I think especially
when you're selling to more mature
companies that need to budget and think
about their uh you know cost profile
using your tool, they need to be able to
predict how that cost is going to scale
not just on an individual developer how
that cost might scale but just generally
throughout the company's buying process.
Um AI is very early so uh speed and and
just showing the value of your product
and people being able to play around and
experiment matters a lot. Uh oftentimes,
at least in this space, it's not like
people are coming to you buying a very
established product. It's kind of your
burden of proof to say, you know, here's
how our agent works. Just go try it and
then start thinking about pricing. So,
so maybe the friction point and where it
is has changed. And then I was saying,
um cogs are variable, but but not only
are they higher, they're also changing
very very quickly. I'm sure everyone in
this room's seen, okay, great. Um you
know, OpenAI uh cut cut model costs by a
third overnight. uh that has a pretty
material impact on like potentially the
underlying cogs of many of these agentic
tools. So um the three key principles
that that I think matter here are like
really thinking about the audience, who
your product is optimized for, what the
value delivery mechanism looks like,
your margin structure, um and and I say
margin structure and not actually
margins because again the underlying
costs are changing very very rapidly. So
you want to think about what are the
axes of scaling rather than what is the
literal margin on day one especially if
you're an earlier product and then you
want to give yourself the flexibility to
experiment over time. This comes with a
lot of complexity but I think it's very
important because you're just not going
to get it right the first time. Um so so
these are kind of the the principles to
keep in mind maybe going through one by
one. Um the the way to kind of think
about pricing for your audience is um
you know h what is their buying journey
and what are they coming to you to to
buy and what value are they looking to
get out of it right uh if you're like I
I we we talked to lots of people who are
like oh you know service now's pricing
is so silly you go to their pricing page
and it says like contact sales it's like
well that's that's a very very different
audience that they're selling to where
they're probably cross-selling some some
existing contract that is a big
enterprise guys commit. They want you to
talk to sales because they really want
to tailor the value to their sales
motion, right? And then on the other
hand, companies that are selling to
individual developers, there's not a
procurement team. There's no purchasing
process. They want you to click try it
and start using the product immediately.
So, so um don't just think about the
kind of point of entry, but think about
who's behind that at the company. Uh is
it going to be a cross functional
decision? Is it something that someone
can just insert into, you know, as as a
vendor on day one or or is there going
to be more of a process around it? And
then also start to kind of think about
uh what users are seeking as quickly as
possible. If they're seeking a proof
point, then perhaps you want to be able
to give them that proof point before you
insert pricing into the equation. Here's
here's an example again using Replet. Um
couple things to note here. uh you'll
see that there's one a lot of tiers and
pricing is actually quite transparent.
Obviously, this is a free tier, right?
Indicating that they want you to see the
value without having to do a ton of
work, think about the monetization. Um
and one thing that's kind of subtle is
often times pricing and packaging really
starts to uh dictate what sort of use
case they are imagining you to use,
right? like um you know what models you
have access to, how many agent
checkpoints you have access to included,
how many seats you might have included.
Uh it it kind of starts positioning your
product. Is it a multiplayer product? Is
it something that people are going to be
using daily or is it something that
you're going to be using, you know,
maybe like five times a month? Uh the
way you package it really determines the
incentives that you're pushing onto your
users and obviously controlling for the
costs that you might pay on the back
end. Here's another example from UniFi,
which is I think a agent agent company,
but it's like targeted at revenue and go
to market teams. One, you'll see that
like the price point is a lot higher.
Um, I want you to like forget whether
it's monthly or annually or any of that.
Just like you come on this page, the
price point is higher. That communicates
something psychologically. And and then
the like second due tiers are custom,
right? Um, again, and maybe the third
thing to point out here is that 50,000
credits, 200,000 credits, 600,000
credits. I I actually don't know what
that means, but that seems like a large
number that communicates something about
the workflows they expect to participate
in and like what that might mean for how
you use UniFi, right? Um, of course,
like it maybe goes in, but the set of
logos you put on your pricing page is
also very important. Um, are you
tailoring it towards okay, we we service
the best developer brands or we service
like Fortune 100 enterprises. Um, and so
pricing is is not just the price point,
but but of course also the the whole
experience of what someone sees when
they land on this page.
Um let's let's talk a little bit about
margins. Um you know as as uh the the
underlying architecture of your product
changes of course your your margins are
going to change. These inputs are
changing very quickly. Um one one
interesting example here is uh you you
as much as possible you want to think
about uh the differentiation of your
product also in R&D innovation and try
to pass that on to your users as
basically pricing leverage. Uh a good
example of this is like Cloudflare has
built their infrastructure on and their
workers infrastructure on these like
isolates right so so they're kind of
lightweight compute machines and so they
can charge for CPU milliseconds and so
if someone is building like an agentic
app on cloudflare and it makes like a
you know call out to openai or enthropic
you're not getting charged for that
because cloudflare is just charging you
for CPU milliseconds instead of wall
time I think that's a really good
example of them you know taking an
architectural bet um which which might
be good for many many reasons, but it's
a really good fit for building AI agents
or generally AI software on top of
Cloudflare. So that's I see that as an
example of like passing down technical
innovation to the end user. Um and then
the other thing to consider about your
margins is you you don't have to protect
them at all costs. You just have to
think about what are the extreme edge
cases and what are you doing to like
prevent those outcomes, right? So if you
have these potentially really degenerate
workloads, how do you incentivize
reasonable usage? you put in rate limits
or guardrails. Um, you don't have to
kind of linearly necessarily scale costs
with usage. You you can protect your
margins potentially in in different
ways. Um, this is an example from
Jasper. I I think this this blog post
and pricing has changed since since I
pulled this example, but you you know,
Jasper realized like, hey, we're
targeted toward marketing teams.
Marketing teams don't want to count
credits like when they're, you know, bas
basically writing marketing copy. And
so, uh, they talk a little bit in this
blog post about how they've architected
around being able to like switch between
models under the hood seamlessly. You
don't have to choose the right model for
the job. And as a result of that, they
went unlimited on uh, each of the three
tiers. So, you're you're no longer
counting credits as you're using Jasper.
Now, uh, this kind of highlights the
core value prop of the product, which is
they want to be a really critical part
of that workflow and they don't want you
to have to like pick and choose when you
use Jasper because you might have
credits or might run out of credits. So,
again, kind of trying to take is there
like an architectural uh advantage you
have and how can you pass that on to
your pricing model. Finally, I want to
talk about flexibility. um you know you
all as as you're working in your teams
uh you're constantly improving your
product you're putting a lot of R&D into
it um one thing that is used to be true
especially in the seatbased world is
like you'd have R&D over here shipping a
ton um increasing the product value and
then you'd have like a once a year okay
we're changing our seat price from $20
to $25. Um, one advantage you have in
the AI world is like, uh, the value is
much closer to the end user. It's not
necessarily like a $20 a seat thing.
It's like someone is literally seeing,
okay, I'm I'm taking this action. This
agent is giving me this output. Okay,
it's getting better. It's getting it's
better. It's getting better. So I think
not only do you as a business have a
responsibility to incrementally evolve
your price as uh you know you invest R&D
but I think it's it's honestly a lot
more understandable for customers why
that's happening because the the
monetization is much closer to the value
of the product. Um so so you know
obviously in Orb's customer base but in
general we are seeing people uh make
many many more price changes not just
once a year or twice a year but in fact
some customers making price changes uh
two three times a month. Um and again
there's there's caveats that come with
that. Uh you have to think about you
know what what is that complexity that
introduces in the in the mental model of
your end users? How are you going to
manage change? Um, and a a a kind of
good internal dynamic example of this is
uh if your go to market team is, you
know, commissioned and and they're
selling these big enterprise contracts
and your pricing is changing or you're
going to like a pay as you go model, you
need to think about like what does that
mean for your sales team? What what does
that mean for the incentives that they
have in selling your product? Classic
example of this is a lot of usage based
companies now commission their sales
reps not on the initial contract land
but on the expansion of that account
over time. And then okay, second order
effect. How do you think about customer
success versus sales as an organization
and how do you organize that internally?
Right? So, so rericing can have lots of
impacts not just on your end user but
also on the internal dynamics of your
org. Um, finally, the thing I'll say is
uh as you're iterating, you you really
want to as much as possible be able to
simulate the impact that this pricing
change is going to have on your users.
In particular, I think uh you want to be
able to simulate uh different usage
patterns. So if you think about your
users and cohorts, um some might be
using it for very different use cases.
What is that revenue mix going to look
like? What is your top uh revenue
generating customer going to how how are
they going to change with a new pricing
model? You you want to be able to do
that in a in a data-informed way,
especially if you're running at a at a
reasonable scale. Here are some
predictions I have as as we're wrapping
up for AI agent pricing. I think um you
know the the price wars will continue.
who we're seeing agents get cheaper and
cheaper. Um and and you know I think
you're we should expect uh people to try
to give effectively unlimited plans. I
think there'll still be caps. I think
there'll still be guard rails but I
think um we we will move to a world
where uh you know people just want these
agents embedded in every workflow. So
we'll try to try to converge to
effectively unlimited. Um I I think
outcome based pricing is going to get
more real. We are seeing some companies
uh do that already. But the the the hard
part about outcome based pricing is
defining what the actual SLA is. Like
what what is the outcome and how do you
measure it and does it make sense to the
end user? Um I I think like we're going
to see a lot of clear definition of
success language and contracts and like
people really trying to get uh precise
about what the outcome is that that
they're charging for. And then um I
think there's going to be a lot more
real-time visibility, spend management,
uh balance alerts. I I think the kind of
workflow around pricing and monetization
is going to get uh more and more
sophisticated. You you think about like
you know obviously in database queries
you have like query planners. I think
it's quite possible that, you know, you
you prompt an agent. It tells you like,
here's my estimate for how much uh how
many credits I'm going to use or hey,
here's three options for um how I might
execute, how I might plan this workload.
One's going to take 10,000 credits, the
other's going to take, you know, 4,000
credits. I think that customer
experience of like being able to control
the workflow around the spend is likely
to get much much more sophisticated um
this year. So just just final note um we
have a whole ebook on how to price your
AI agent that goes into much more
tactical advice talks about specific you
know threshold billing fraud prepaid
pricing models um if you want to check
that out that is at this link. Thank
you.
[Music]